then we do this where we at time wise or
an hour was incredible what that by fast
quick but we're not done we do a thing
at the end called unhelpful advice and
we have emails and we answer them you
can be wrong to be right however you
want to do it uh-huh go ahead my friend
unhelpful advice with Bobby
kalila Jamaa neighbors I've just started
dating a girl that's about nine inches
taller than me I'm 5-1 and she's 510 I'm
having a very hard I'm having a great
time with her but she gets mad at me
because I don't like to show public
displays of expression like holding
hands or kissing in public I already
feel like we get looks in people and
public trying to figure us out and I
don't like getting extra attention
especially when drunk people around and
shout at us have you guys ever ran to a
situation like this over the years any
advice I mean that's the every girl ever
friend I've ever had years ago maybe
like 10 years ago just got my car my
Nissan 300zx two-seater either way so I
go pick her up
I go pick her up and she's big yeah and
I was like but she had a great face yeah
you know yeah get her in my car and [ __ ]
like that dude she's the biggest [ __ ]
she had to be like at least three Wow
so she no three years of age so I was
like fine whatever you know she gets my
car and she I sort of got the car was
literally it's a Brynner Nissan Z X so
it was so I was like whatever so we go
to go see that movie with the rock when
he when he had that daughter or whatever
he played football with her and all that
[ __ ] or yeah the game plan yeah yeah we
go see the game plan or whatever with
her and [ __ ] my car's [ __ ] leaning it
was kind of raining and [ __ ] yeah
because we hit a [ __ ] pothole in the
car
[ __ ] spun out and it was but it but
it but it was going towards her away so
I knew that she had a little bit to do
with this asked me do I have insurance
no do you have did you make it to the
movie mm-hmm oh you didn't my wheel came
off yeah are you being real I'm being a
while here is you get head from wherever
so what happened was Covina my wheel
came off I did him a triple a we so my
best friend came to come pick us up when
we stayed at his house and then so my
black ass was still trying to get some
head but she was mad you know so yeah
you [ __ ] up my car no dinner do you
get dinner no movie nothing
she got nothing out of it so go back to
this guy yeah well I'm saying well I'm
saying this girl was like at least a
hundred pounds bigger than me so Ryan I
mean no [ __ ] with her dude yeah yeah man
yeah don't [ __ ] with her all right kiss
her that means that yes she has to meal
that's it that's embarrassing haha that
is true you're right you know what he's
not right wrong because with he's 5 1
he's five-nine five-ten imagine like oh
look at the kid and her mom like just so
many different like mom and son
references mmm and jokes
he's probably paranoid yeah I would be
paranoid absolutely yeah they're asking
if you and I have any issues with a
height the French it's not that much
it's 5 inches yeah that's true it's not
that's not
and you know and you know what he likes
he likes it when I wear heels the taller
the better I also like it when my
girlfriends and they're always you know
you're like the
Honus girl right I like that yeah I love
it I like showing white kids that don't
know who I am yeah but you know what
that's what happened that person is not
wrong cuz we have been shouted at a lot
but you know like what like they just
get real angry and they sort of throw
like a it's not because of height though
with the reason why they get English cuz
you're hot and I'm not I think people
get viscerally white dudes especially
get this early angry that I'm dating a
hot chick you don't think you're hot
I think he thought he's pretty hot what
the [ __ ] yeah no gay [ __ ] why'd you
throw that out just in case I just said
no no no let me ask you this okay and be
completely honest with me alright
the doorman and those kind of guys at
the store think I'm gay no you never
heard anything no because there's a
couple there's oh and whenever it comes
to like either you're a small black eye
or you're a hefty black guy and you're
working at The Comedy Store I harass
them not you know races away in a love
way yeah I just like [ __ ] around with
black dudes
that's like look at Ian Edwards Edwards
is when he sees me he has to run because
I love to grap all I love to like yeah
one room in door I know doesn't want to
come close to you anymore
he's just kind of standoffish with
that's why I think I think that there is
a provide out there but if you're saying
there there is no vibe there is no vibe
I've never thank God thank God we've got
to get you an agent tomorrow and get you
out there but that's why that's dude
that's why you and I are very similar in
that way I think as performers